in a world where first person shooters
are a dime a dozen anyone who has played
the original battlefield games or grew
up with later entries such as
battlefield 4
can tell you their favorite moments when
interacting with the game's use of
destruction
what's up all i'm david and destruction
in battlefield has to be one of my
absolute favorite aspects of the
franchise
from its first release in battlefield
bad company to the unreleased
battlefield 6
there is one thing that the franchise
will guarantee it's environmental
destruction over the course of a match
let's take a look at how the series uses
destruction and levolution
and just what makes it so special we'll
also take a quick moment to speculate on
the rumors of what destruction and
battlefield 6 could look like
now if you're excited for battlefield 6
make sure to like this video so you'll
always be the first to know be sure to
hop in the comments too afterwards
if you really want to help us out hit
that bell button it's free
let's get started
before battlefield went on to the
frostbite engine destruction in the game
mainly involved very minor specific
parts of the level
bridges are a common example and in
games like battlefield 2
bridges could be destroyed with
explosives this basic form of
destruction quickly evolved as
battlefield transitioned to the
frostbite engine
which gave the game a lot more firepower
pun intended
and creating a dynamic world that would
rock your screen with explosions and
shock waves
adding a level of immersion that went
beyond just what you saw on screen
but instead threw you into the middle of
what was basically a
massive interactive sandbox with
battlefield bad company 2
we also got a more complex system of
destruction entire objects would no
longer disappear at once
instead buildings trees and roadways
would crumble over the course of a match
if you nailed one side of a house it
wouldn't just go full on kaput but with
enough of the walls being blown out the
roof would eventually collapse
creating a big pile of rubble that could
kill any enemies still inside
battlefield 3 built on this with the
introduction of micro destruction
so you didn't need grenade launchers or
rockets to break walls
your standard assault rifles would do
the trick if you would chip away at
smaller barricades walls and furniture
eventually you would start noticing the
decay there was a trade-off with this
however
sure more things would be visually
destroyed but it wasn't as significant
and the scale was much smaller leaving
less of the environment to actually be
destructible
battlefield 3 essentially traded away
larger destruction
for better overall looks the solution to
this in my opinion
ended up being the next logical step of
destruction gradual changes to the map
that take effect over the course of an
entire match which is where battlefield
went on to invent
the levolution so first things first
let's talk about the difference between
destruction and levolution
destruction was prevalent in the
battlefield games listed so far
and is basically part of the game's
identity but levolution refers very
specifically to large-scale destruction
events in battlefield 4
which to me is honestly the holy grail
and perfect balance of destruction
the concept on paper is simple each
multiplayer round in battlefield 4
has a sort of timeline attached to the
map so long certain parameters are met
so by the time you're in the latter half
of the round chances are
a major set piece or sometimes huge
portions of the map
would look nothing like it did when you
first started and we're not talking just
small roadways or bridges being removed
i'm talking big-ass skyscrapers in siege
of shanghai that had an objective on the
roof spectacularly collapsing into a
colossal pile of rubble
there are plenty of other areas like
this in other battlefield 4 maps
where as long as specific areas took
damage or had certain parameters met
sometimes dramatic consequences could
have resulted battlefield hardline also
had some revolution set pieces
though not as intense as battlefield 4.
still
you could knock a giant crane into a
building to create new path between
objectives
or even have a bank vault come crashing
through the roof during a heist
hardline did an excellent job of keeping
the environment around you versatile
and somewhat unpredictable at least in
the early stages before you got really
acclimated with its gameplay
unfortunately for me levolution did not
stick around
instead battlefield 1 introduced
behemoths that would wreak
absolute havoc the regretted to the
losing side in matches is a way to
even the odds but were criticized for
tipping the balance a little too
favorably in either direction
they were technically some map specific
destroyable sections in battlefield 1
but this was nowhere close to the scale
of levolution
battlefield v would go on to ditch
behemoths and levolution
despite keeping some building
destruction intact in favor of a toolbox
in battlefield v anyone could create
cover at fixed locations
and support classes could incorporate
extra variety or build roots between
areas
this new mechanic was enough to alter
the flow of certain maps
but again it just didn't have the same
degree of grandness
or spectacle that the iconic levolutions
had
and often battles focused on the same
preset fortification spots over and over
again
but now for the exciting stuff because
this brings us to battlefield 6.
rumor has it that massive destruction
will be making a return
which is great for several reasons we're
in the midst of a new console generation
so the brutal frame rate dips on my old
xbox during destruction
should be a thing of the past with both
the series x and the ps5 equipped with
better specs
those lucky enough to own a next-gen
console or a high-end pc
are hoping to reap the benefits of
better looking destruction levolution
could be a great way to create a
climactic moment in any given round
a visual turning point showing that the
home stretches in sight
now i know it's not for everyone and i'm
sure there are those who didn't care
or felt that levolution in particular
could grow stale after a while
but battlefield 6 could have a solution
to taking the dynamism up another notch
through a revamped weather system the
rumor is that the weather system will
incorporate natural disasters in the
form of massive storms
we've gotten slight glimpses of extreme
weather in battlefield 4 with huge
rainstorms causing choppier surf like in
paracel storm
leading to less accurate naval combat
and tougher visibility
but battlefield 6 might even go so far
as to include weather ranging from
storms
all the way to straight up tornadoes now
if or when these rumors are confirmed
and battlefield 6 is revealed
we can get a gauge into the scope of how
dramatic this extreme weather could get
but as far as i'm concerned
this stuff sounds absolutely bat crazy
it's tornadoes it's certainly a lot to
be excited and optimistic about
especially if dice can play the cards
right
there's also no official word yet if
battlefield 6 will come out on last gen
consoles
my hope is that it stays next-gen
exclusive so there's more effort on
pumping out as much visual fidelity in
the destruction as possible
we'll have a better idea of what will
actually be possible in battlefield 6 in
the coming days
and we'll be sure to share our thoughts
and impressions of everything we see
so what did you prefer the organic
destruction of that company
levolution from battlefield 4 or even
those massive behemoths from battlefield
1. be sure to sound off into the
comments and tell us what kind of
destruction you'd like to see
in battlefield 6. now here's some quick
examples of my favorite evolutions from
battlefield 4 to close us off
because they're just that good thanks
for watching
[Music]
objective
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
you